Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop in our previous video
We showed you the beginning steps of building a tabletop fire pit now
We're going to take all of the pieces that we've prepped before and permanently assemble them into a fire pit
Let's start by soldering the long coil with the two elbows and the small straight piece in between
Solder and copper pipe properly does take a little bit of prep work
So let's clean up all of the joints so that the bond will be strong
There's a tool that's made for cleaning out the inside of copper joints that looks kind of like cone-shaped wire brush
But unfortunately I also don't have one of those so I am using some very fine grit sandpaper
Wrapped around the end of a pen it's actually working pretty well
There we have it, we've prepped and cleaned all of the copper pieces that will make connections
Before we can solder our copper pipes together
we do have to add a little bit of flux this helps the solder flow evenly and not oxidize I
Also need to apply a little bit to the inside joint. This is of course a much larger brush than is necessary
To get this solder to take and really seal well on this copper pipe
what I need to do is heat up the joint a lot and then tap the solder onto it if it's properly heated with the
Flux added correctly it should pull the liquid solder into the gap and seal it up
Everyone out there who's way better at soldering copper pipe than I am please don't make fun of me too much
I haven't done this much before at all
- on it
Well it's ugly, but I think it's soldered
Hey that one actually turned out pretty good
There's probably some very specific way to know when you're at the perfect temperature so that the solder will melt and flow nicely
But it's not just gonna burn and fall off. I don't know what that method is
Now we've got the top coil of our fire pit all assembled
It's soldered together, and I'm pretty sure it's even airtight
Which is just what we want not bad for my second time ever soldering copper pipe learning new skills today. It's good
let's solder a straight piece on then pass it through the pan and
Then we'll attach the second piece on the outside if we attach all of these right here
We won't be able to fit it through our pan anymore because this hole is only large enough for the smaller fitting not for this
larger one
Oh
It's pretty good now let's pop that down through the pan careful because it is quite hot
Seems pretty well attached everywhere got some good solder on there if it's good to go
You just want to let it cool down a little bit our piping is all soldered together
We've let it cool down to the point where it's no longer difficult to touch
Let's attach this to our fuel line and then fit it inside our plastic container
beautiful
Alright, that's looking good, but at this point if we were to turn on the gas
It would have nowhere to go
what we need to do is drill some holes into our copper pipe up on top so the fuel has somewhere to escape to I
Have here about the smallest drill bit that will fit into this Chuck and still actually grip on if I go too small
There's a little bit of a hole down the center of the different teeth and it'll just slide in and out
But I think this size should be good, so I'm just going to put several holes going around this copper tube
And that's where the propane butane fuel mixture will come out
The copper tube in the top now has holes drilled in it
So it should be ready to test lighting on fire, but some of you may have caught on to the fact that so far
It's pretty difficult to turn on the gas
Inside this container if I just tried to twist the handle as it is I'd have to open it and then attach
The lid and the whole time propane and butane would be spewing into the air
That's no good
So what we want to do is give ourselves a way to turn the gas on and off while the lid is attached
So first let's take off this small wire handle the plan is that we'll drill a small hole into the side of the plastic
through that we'll have a length of straightened copper tube which can reach in and
turn the little key that lets the gas come out at the moment if you put it on into swivels and doesn't turn it at
All we'll flatten the tube so that it fits nicely onto our key
Looks like just the right height now we want to use a bit
That's just larger than our copper pipe so that it'll easily fit in including the flattened end designed to fit over the key
Let's just take some sandpaper in our pen and clean up that edge a little bit in the end it probably won't even be very
Visible, but it's just nicer if it's clean
You can now fit the copper pipe through the side of the container and it fits perfectly over the key
Let's flatten the end of our tube so that it can actually get some grip on our gas key
the fuel can is inside the plastic container we can now reach through with our piece of copper pipe fit it over the key and
Open the gas
Since we don't want to have an extra foot of copper pipe sticking out at all times
Let's just mark off where we want to cut this
Our piece is cut down
We've cleaned up the edge and at this point a copper cap fits nicely over it so this will work as our key
To turn our gas on and off our copper pipe fits nicely over the fuel key
But I am going to try and crimp it down a little more so it's a little bit more of a snug fit and won't
Bend or warp the copper when we try and turn it on and off
That works great so to finish up this piece, so let's clean up the edges and solder the cap on
Our copper pipe key is now finished, so let's try putting everything together and do a rough test to see if this is working
It's looking pretty good
See what happens if we turn this key
Look at that
How big can it go
Really big, too big
Turn that down a bit again, that is
beautiful
It's coming out perfectly nice. Even flames all the way around our circle
excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent! whoo!
Yes, all right I'm gonna turn it off by twisting the key
Perfect that worked great oh, I'm excited. I love when things work well
Well at this point what we need to do is make it look a little bit nicer
It's working great, but it looked kind of boring
So let's take some
Decorative elements add those on and really make this thing with nice our base being made of clear plastic is really nice while we're building
It because we can see everything that's going on inside
But it doesn't really look very professional when you can just look at your fuel tank
I want to decorate the outside of the plastic container
And then I also have these blue pieces of glass that I want to put in the bed above the fire coil
What we're going to do is take these paint sticks cut them down to the height of our plastic container
And then use some hot glue to glue them on going all the way around of course
We'll have to drill a hole in one of the sticks so that our key can still fit in and out
I'm actually going to just measure up to the brackets because our pan will be on top and we'll never really be able to see
this piece of the clear plastic
This way I don't have to fit them around each single bracket
Let's start with the slat that we need to drill a hole into to fit over our key
Let's put a little mark right where we want the center of the hole to be
Looks nice
Perfect he slides in and out
Beautiful let's take some hot glue apply it to the inside of our cut paint stick and then glue it in place on the container
Our first ones in place now. Let's just go around the rest of the container adding paint sticks all the way
All right, we've got one spot left
That's just slightly wider than our last paint stick so we are gonna have to trim this down to make it fit
Beautiful there we go that looks pretty nice now
Let's just take these glass beads and add them all around on the inside of our pan
I
Got these beads at Hobby Lobby they come in these little net bags
I bought two of the bags and each bag was only like three dollars, so it's pretty cheap
I think it would be fine if the glass were right on top of the pipe
But I am trying to clear a path just a little bit so the gas has somewhere to go
It's looking pretty good, I think at this point what we have to do is turn it on and see how it looks oh
That's fantastic
Thank you that a little tabletop
fire pit a
Lot of good heat coming off of that too that looks so cool. I love the contrast the orange fire with the blue glass
That's why I chose the blue glass. It's just they look really good together
Wow, that looks so cool. I'm just gonna turn it up
Bigger fire always more fun
Wow that is a hoot, that's the dumbest expression I've ever used I hope you're here
I do want to point out that while this is small enough to fit on a tabletop
It's really not something that you want to use indoors for any extended period of time
Propane and butane unless they're burned
100% can let off carbon monoxide gases
And you can see that there's smoke coming off of here both of those are stuff
You don't want inside your house for any long period of time
There you have it a fire pit is a super fun thing to gather around if you don't have one
This is easier to build than it is to install one in your yard
It's not gonna put out the same amount of heat of course, but it does work pretty well
There's a good amount of heat coming off of this and of course I can turn it up even more if I want well. That's
Toasty very toasty very quickly this whole build only takes a few hours
And it's pretty fun to do I especially enjoyed learning the new skill of soldering the copper together although some people out there probably think
What I did looked pretty sloppy it worked. Well. It's airtight and for a first time. It's not bad
Thanks for joining us for this project today, and we look forward to the next one talk to you then
This is better at night, I got a five, but then sits on your table now
What won't they think of next?
Hey guys grant here
Just want to pop in with a quick update that the king of random brand is
Expanding Nate's here because you wanted more DIY more variety more frequent videos and together. We're all making that happen. Thanks for your support